no the vagina and the [ __ ] very close
there's a taint in the middle of a small
very small tank
is that my dad will talk about this all
day now now we're on to the subjects
that i'm comfortable with
the asshole's not going to sue you
no actually i am being sued by an
[ __ ] for defamation named brian
cavanaugh
so let me ask you this the fact that
you're being sued now for defamation
don't you think you're juggling a little
bit by just even saying what you say oh
no now no because this is defaming it
can be considered that no oh it's not
defamation if it's true howie that's
what we just learned in johnny depp and
amber heard
right it's not definitely so get this
he's suing me for defamation variety
wrote an article that said with the
title of it was
ryan cavanaugh was accused of his ex
part by his ex-partner of running a
ponzi scheme
so i printed that headline i put it
behind me
and uh was you know i i was just i was
really acknowledging this headline of
course there's of some additional
context that i learned later that the
article was retracted
or no the claim by his partner was
retracted so that's what he's suing me
for defamation because i read the
headline of a variety article it's
insane
um oh so it's not stuff that you you
were literally just regurgitating i was
just reading the headline of a variety
so then why isn't he suing the variety
that's a really good question
because he could get right it's a growth
variety
yeah now he's going to sue very very
very very variety
he already threatened them and
it's a grudge lawsuit he initially sued
us for copyright infringement for
showing like a five second clip of one
of his trailer fights he's like he owns
trailer now
and um
i've been sued once for copyright
infringement before won it it's one of
the uh
one of the strongest precedents in for
fair use the only one really for fair
use on youtube was a big deal
and so i'm very passionate about fair
use and uh copyright infringement and
that kind of stuff like that as someone
that you know is regularly commenting on
stuff so when ryan kavanaugh stepped to
me and he sued us for copyright
infringement i said oh hell [ __ ] no
so
we started to fight this copyright
infringement lawsuit and uh we had a
little fun with ryan cavanaugh it's not
fun i was just telling you know the the
guy is a piece of [ __ ] so there's plenty
out him in fact check out his wikipedia
article man that thing is an incredible
read
start to end i mean wow
but so anyone can write in a wikipedia
page too wikipedia is very credible
these days really yes anybody can edit
it that's not true anymore no no they've
stopped that they put it into it
wikipedia is quite is very credible
these days well sourced you have to be
like a an editor and stuff you can't
just go edited page willy-nilly uh howie
i i know that from 30 rock remember they
did an episode where i don't know back
in the day you could but anyway yeah so
i'm in this whole it's a grudge lawsuit
so he he is suing me for copyright
infringement we poked a little bit of
fun at him talk some [ __ ] and then um he
sued me for tortious interference
because he got a bunch of one stars on a
shitty app trailer by the way and if you
want to leave a one-star review on
trailer
um that's fine if that's the experience
you had right
like like howie if you wanted to go to
that obviously i'll just keep saying
allegedly yeah i know
i don't know but they're not going to
get sued for telling people to go to no
no no no what i'm saying is this we won
this lawsuit by the way so don't worry
oh good
i was saying howie if you don't like
trailer and why would you it's a
horrible app
if you wanted to go to to that you know
if you wanted if you went to the app
store yeah
and wanted to give it a one star review
that would be a good thing to do as long
as it was honest because obviously you
know one right five stars but if you
gave it a one star review and you hated
the app that would be honest right to do
and they're looking for feedbacks would
be a good thing to do for them and so
they got a lot of one-star reviews so he
sued me for tortious interference that
one got thrown out we're about to get
attorneys fees and everything on that so
[ __ ] you ryan cavanaugh
and then the other one is um
defamation copyright infringement
torches and fears we won we also have a
website give me a favor this is my
favorite episode we've had so far just
to see my dad squirm yeah i'm like i
knew you were i knew you were vanilla so
i wanted to push so far
google ryan kavanagh oh my god can't it
he he you know he paid for the house and
the check went through
yeah but that's that was probably how
long ago was that alex how long ago did
we sell that house
he probably had money then he's broke
now he's a loser go down he's divorced
too
or not that there's anything wrong with
that but um
i don't know why i said how many things
are you throwing out there that could
possibly cause
sorry no yeah that's our website does
ryan cavanaugh look like harvey
weinstein oh my god and it's actually
it's actually usually number one there's
nothing wrong i i didn't mean to say he
got divorced uh that i just want to roll
that back there's nothing wrong with
that but this is the one thing so far
that you've been talking about that you
want to roll back well because there's
nothing wrong with with getting divorced
the thing i was getting at is that um
there's this guy brad the bull
who's like railing his wife but that's
not here nor there
god
oh my god oh my god
but anyway yeah but that's what i'm
saying right so i says so i says look
but don't they look similar and they're
both producers
and i'm saying they do look similar so
this is a public service we're doing and
it's usually what does that have to do
with anything that they look similar i'm
sure that they're people are confused
they're confusing but no longer
scroll down go ahead keep scrolling down
who's controlling it back there yeah so
take a look at the slide here uh scroll
back and forth and we put this together
as a public service so that people could
really tell the difference between these
two men public service yes of course so
are people getting confused were they
getting confused i mean is this what
he's suing you for this website he tried
to he sued us to remove the website we
won so that's what i was saying we won
two of four lawsuits
why because you're allowed what did it
cost you to to defend this
oh you know a lot
you probably would be north of 60
million had you not had to defeat yeah
yeah yeah
i mean i've spent
i've spent so much money on attorneys
yeah and you say you're not about the
drama what are you estimating this is
true but i don't back down from this
[ __ ] billionaire loser bully who's
trying to trample on my right to free
speech [ __ ] that guy he thinks because
he's rich he can sue and bully people
what she's done by the way his whole
career he's a litigious piece of [ __ ]
and he stepped to me he even wrote me a
threatening dm before he he goes your
little toy podcast you better watch what
you're doing because you're playing
around with real people and i said [ __ ]
you [ __ ] i showed the message and guess
what i've won two of four he's about to
pay my attorney's fees on the torches
interference one and um
the only person really making out better
than this is his wife by the way and you
should see the guy she's dating now he's
jacked brad the bull really good guy
he's [ __ ] the [ __ ] out of his wife
ex-wife
i don't know if they're still married
wikipedia says they're still married
but you should see this guy he's [ __ ]
jack bro
so he's a ball um
go down go down
i feel like oh yeah uh oh noah back yeah
he said of the triller app my thing is
flipped anyway go keep going down guys
down down
yeah
down
then so this is the issue here's ryan
cavanaugh kissing harvey weinstein and
we're like well wow uh seeing them
together is really confusing so we need
public service again yeah and they keep
going down yeah keep going down okay
yeah
why is that a public service
that was um to help distinguish him more
from from
some people don't get confused that's
good we did a whole dui of this
controversy can you guys scroll out a
little bit so i can when you played this
on your podcast is this what you got
sued for
no no no just the variety thing so the
variety this is even more
no he didn't sue us for this howie that
because it's true still time right so
kavanaugh's dui's you know he got he got
uh so many cat uh
he's he's lost his license and it's a
whole mess uh he's correct he had a hit
and run and from the dui i mean it was a
whole mess howie go down keep going down
uh hold your kids lying under oath how
old are your kids that's the one i told
you about we're almost done and then go
to the left you have a five-year-old and
a brand new one
so this is this is the one we're getting
in the carriage this is the one you're
getting sued so let's get let's skip
this keep going down the kid's the baby
the baby is that two boys unpaid wages
he got sued by a former babysitter for
stiffing her babysitter
175 000 do you have a living
do you do it all you're nursing your
wife nursing
why are you laughing should we finish
we're almost done i feel like i'm almost
done
and then go down and go to the left well
howie you invited me i mean no i did i
did invite you and i'm not so this one's
about me i love it yeah and i love the
drama i love i well i'm also a huge fan
of reality
television television
television too i just love
drawing not being a part of it but
listening
maybe i don't want to get sued you're
not i'm you're you've made it very clear
that i'm not you are not a part of this
right is it clear to the people that are
sitting out there have i made it clear
that this is just him right he's saying
it i don't know if any of it is true
well i'm not i'm not condoning it i mean
you have to have a big a legend i'm just
giving him his forehead allegedly on his
forehead which means you cannot be sued
you cannot be sued really yeah no will
you uh you pay the legal fees absolutely
not go down
so this is the message he sent me can
you believe this no don't put this up
get past this i mean get past this
govern yourself
but don't you hate bullies
elon musk
elon musk believes in freedom of speech
he paid for amber heard's attorneys
maybe he'll pay for this if you get in
trouble too i think it's so much you
don't need to show all this you know if
you have a message just [ __ ] in
somebody's bed that's what i've always
see that's illegal
[Music]
bye